not exactly the ability to but some of
my best friends
and United if you notice that I not
speaking straighten mark but now that
I am very pleased to be here and
variegated this discussion you may
wonder why we chose to have it today not
just more or less now betrayed and i'll
give you one reasons that it was
announced today french media that
Consuela was finally getting married and
everyone said wow this really
illustration of his dedication to
marriage for all that's his contribution
on the course it's April Fool's Day and
that may be one reason why we chose to
have this event today there's a second
reason is that it's Easter Monday oh and
it would have been interesting to have a
discussion about this given the
importance of the Catholic Church debate
in France and there's an elven
comparison which I find particularly
revealing which is the fact that in the
US according to polls Catholics tend to
be more favorable than the population on
average mentoring a marriage and as you
know that's the opposite in the French
context that's an indication of how we
should not presume that we know how it
works before we checked how it works
that is we cannot expect just because we
do something to say about the Catholic
Church they will know how Catholic
voters react when such issues what
matters it's not just sort of abstract
so cultural logic by political context
and historical context which is very
much the compartment that I tried to do
one last reason why we're having this on
April first is that in two thousand and
one of the Netherlands was the first
country to of the marriage to same-sex
couples I'm a pro first now that makes a
difference because in fact some of the
arguments that have been used in France
about and I will return to this but
about the universality of sexual
difference that makes it impossible to
have such a thing as same-sex marriage
have been empirically weakened by the
dissemination of same-sex marriage now
what I want to do is to expand on this
with a line that I have tried to melt at
the last 15 years or 20 years actually
before discussions about the same sex
marriage all the critique of culturalism
the use of the parasitic recipe was for
me is precisely that it helps undermine
the illusion that we can understand
something about France because it's
essentially French or something about
because it's essentially American and
one of the interests for me of having
tried to think of this comparison of a
long time is that you can see how both
sides have changed considerably and in
particular it seems to me that one
element that is most surprising and was
unexpected for people who've been
interested in this issue for a long time
is the illusion of public opinion in the
u.s. it was difficult to assume all the
ten years ago all that Albuquerque would
also rapidly in the US it was very easy
to rely on serving cultural assumptions
all that confirmed ideas that we had
about the u.s. so this is kind of our
games that I will use my critique of
culturalism I had a chance to try and
develop of many years ago during the
patch debate we had a discussion with
colleague whose work I really respect
admire about nine who we had this
conversation about facts and his
argument was how can you understand the
fact
so much resistance and France to pass
and we found go to historical reasons
why the French might be reluctant to
quote some type of civil union to
same-sex couples I was more interested
in the opposite version that is how is
it possible that could change not only
because of my reluctance to engage in
culturist arguments but also because I'm
interested in this issue politically
that is if you want to think about the
possibility of change then you have to
have a good theoretical reason for
thinking that it's possible because if
you find good reasons why things cannot
change then of course because we helped
to have any head with balloon or vision
issues oh one element that is quite
interesting to compare kinds of us is
the evolving place of religion 15 years
ago when you babe I the past took place
of one striking moment which I have
past was when this kingdom perfect
Christian or intervened in public
assembly in the National Assembly with
Bible and this was criticized on all
sides everyone agreed that in France we
don't do them we're not supposed to have
high levels in the National Assembly
that's on French why is French it was
arguing the secular by contrast of
course when I told the story of the u.s.
their homes laughing horse of us you're
bound to have a Bible in the National
sembuh of also my voice recipes
and so what what struck me at the times
that it was very tempting to think well
this has to do with eternal grants
eternal secular republic congrats on one
hand on the other hand of this have to
do with this earth eternal logistic
America however things have changed oh
and it helps realize how these are not
going to his eternal always in the case
of France in particular what we've seen
in the last few months is the
overwhelming presence of religion debate
team oh and the Solidarity between
political parties on the right and
religious institutions so instead of
this internally second of France what we
see is that sailors in today means in
fact that you can have industries people
representing the Catholic Church
demonstrating alongside of people
represented by trading party that's
quite the different I think from what
people assumed was essentially French 15
years ago so I want to try and see why
has there been such a shit well one
element is that 15 years to French
debate on the past and what was most
impressive eight that I will approach in
comparisons of times with the American
situation on the French side 15 years
ago but we had as you may recall was a
kind of ethical logical argument the
idea was that the essence of culture was
at stake and some refer to
psychoanalysis some refer to an apology
per se in summary for religion all three
coincided change but what was
interesting to me is that of this
perception of an entomological logic of
seemed very exotic from American
overview and I want to say one team
others how come it was necessary to
resort to entomological our use and
fresh hummus why use laser ops instead
of the Bible oh and I think the answer
is that in France and you can still see
this enables people are not supposed to
be homophobic oh you look at recent
polls for example despite all the
demonstrations that you've seen that
didn't see
to be the opposite of homophobic still
you have more than eighty percent of
population that say oh that there's no
problem with my sexuality more than
eighty percent and people who say it
might be a problem you know about seven
percent who said it's a perversion and
sick person who saves a disease but that
means only thirteen percent so 87 on one
side and 13 the other so basically no
one and Curren is homophobic which is
great what it means is that if you're
against gay marriage you cannot just say
because there's a problem with gays
since we're not going fully so the way
you're going to justify proposing
same-sex marriage is by having other
kinds of arguments that have nothing to
do in case it has anything to say with
sexual difference which is very
different from sexual orientation so no
one is completely therefore if you want
to be against it the only way to be
against it is my other kinds of
arguments hence the fact that
to help illogical arguments now what is
in case that when we look today these
ethological arguments that were using
the time of including by the church have
more or less disappeared you don't hear
so much psychoanalysis info you don't
hear so much this grouse and coat oh how
come well the first reason in my opinion
is that it didn't work the first time
and so it's difficult to use it a second
time so basically if you say they're
universal laws established by it such
important writers as Libby Strauss and
black on etc well how come it's been
possible to have this cuts in the first
place and how it's possible also to have
it in the Netherlands how come it's
possible to have it to melt it etcetera
etc so universal laws of that stuff to
the borders of France seem less
University so in anyways the argument is
now less culture but more about our
culture Oh which of course is something
that was familiar in the US and there
was something about the OC Hardwick a
decision of that insisted that yeah I
know it's not part of our culture we
don't do that we Americans don't and
because the Bible Bible civic isn't
oh that's readily new in French context
because in fact the ideas that we embody
universalism and therefore there was no
specificity of this fish now the fact
that today it's less in topology and
more it can go ethnology that is more
our culture and less culture % o is not
the only element that has changed
there's a second element which i think
is equally important oh it's the
importance of biology biology was not
used so much as an argument at the
during the discussions about the past I
think has played much more important
word in the last few years value to this
for two years to debate about the
introduction of the so-called theory of
gender in biology textbooks in high
school oh you may recall that at first
the attack was launched again by testing
boot camp oh who is the spokesperson for
Catholic associations in France and then
by the so-called wat po Judea whose
competence on biology had not been
almost visible until then okay
physically coders have been on
integration issues now what was
interesting is that this attracted a lot
of attention oh and Mike you have many
deputies and we having senators who join
in saying that would be a major problem
to introduce the cervical theory of
gender in biology textbooks now at worst
they didn't invent this issue they
borrowed this issue from Vatican
theology of vatican theology and this is
what our connections as we discovered
the common interest for this sex
reduction of the vatican difficult
passion to confess so what was so
interesting about this is that own of
course the Vatican has been developing
arguments against gender starting with
Beijing conference in 1995 and one of
the ways in which gender could be
proposed of since the theaters that
gender would d naturalize society and in
particular d naturalized sexual
difference and also be naturalized the
institutions that today and bodies so to
speak sexual difference such as marriage
and family so the fears of Vatican where
that the world would we be naturalized
in there were natural law should return
at the center of Baghdad blg but not
just a natural all natural log and see
as the laws of nature that is instead of
being divine reason
or more biology so it's got as nature if
you with this you have seen for example
in recent pronouncements by the Pope all
arguing for human ecology human ecology
as both explain of the former prophetic
as he explained in 2011 that we've all
just before Christmas he claimed that
the problem with our Ecology's that were
only interested in aqua forests and we
should also be interested in
heterosexual marriage comparison that I
leave
Oh sort of Halton sexual American now
what was interesting is that this
argument of human ecology has been
influential because you find this
argument and it's phrased human ecology
used by the main rabbi and France to the
allowing the text that he published
during the recent debate on same-sex
marriage and Friends of Texas why widely
circulated because it was presented by
man is very reasonable of texts rosing
sex marriage now this religious
rehabilitation of nature how is
interesting but there's another question
which is why has religion been
rehabilitated and public discourse and
it seems to me that if you compare 1997
to 90 99 to you today you can see the
difference all the church is not in the
closet any longer it's very much in the
streets now how well it seems to me that
this has very much to do with the years
of new good at subtlety and the
discussions about national identity as
we know the national
by faculty was presented on the one hand
as this secular France all that we all
believe in and as is essentially
Catholic friends that we all believe it
it was simultaneously eternally secular
friends and apparently Catholic friends
the conjunction of the tooth Essex
national identity so many ways the fact
that religion was instrumentalized
politically as part of our national
identity gain political dominance to
religion and in many ways it's not
surprising that you see the same people
who streets of side by side in the name
of religion and politics it's not
exactly new that's what's been happening
in France to the last few years so the
only difficulty horse-trading Zarb islam
cannibal pretentious
now what I want to argue now is that all
this evolution that's taking place and
France helps rephrase the question that
we can start we start with the question
what specific about what's going on in
France and what interests me in fact is
more how things have changed that is how
it's not something that is inherent car
culture but how it's the politics of
French culture so how it's not national
identity by the politics of national
identity that are at stake so the
comparison between friends in the US is
not a comparison between two natural
identities but between battles political
battles in both countries about the
interpretation the definition of
national identity and one element for
i'm sending this I think is race and
this is what I want to develop now that
is it seems to me that may of the
differences that we can see between the
debates in France and the in the US have
to do with rates I'll start with one
issue that has been very much simpler
debates taking place in both countries
for the last 15 years it's the
difference between why I have called the
synchronization of marriage in case of
the US and the civilization of so-called
filiation in the case of France
affiliation that is of the legal
institution of the family through
adoption through access to reproductive
technologies and also true biological
reproduction the same realization of
marriage in the u.s. because it seems to
me that the debate that is taking place
in the US and today says little about
the issue of pedestrian there's in fact
it's a different issue of the discussion
whether people should adopt or not
whether they should have access to
reproductive technologies for now is
largely separate in the discussion about
marriage / safe only perhaps as a way of
saying since of gays and lesbians
already have cadence we might as well
into marriage but in France as you know
what it works the other around that is
it's one thing to get the marriage but
should we want to go so far as to give
them more is adoption rights and rights
productive technologies so it's the
opposite version and that's not new now
how can we interpret this and you see
this in holes for example pipetting
parents people are more likely to
approve marriage sent to approval
reduction and more likely to approve an
adoption that you approve the pack
sister with your doctor technologies
mobile returns now my argument has been
for a while that this has to do grace
that is the fact that marriage is racial
you shouldn't eat less in particular the
questions children born out of wedlock
is an extremely racialized issue as was
indicated by the joke that Obama made a
couple years ago when he said that he's
been accused with everything by Fox News
including on having fathered children in
wedlock and it seems to be the joe says
much about the racial implications of
this whereas it seems to be of the
debate in france about psg and the same
realization
asian has to do with race but in a
different way it has to do with
integration with whose french issue
whose french has been more and more
defined in racial terms that is terms of
origin that sushi real issue and it
seems to me that these terms have played
an important role in segment blood
matters in defining friendship today
more than before Oh hence of this
incision some people were not just any
good but we can be second generation or
third generation or 4th generation
immigrants which means they've been
friends forever they're still considered
eagle now that sickness on broad oh now
what was so interesting for me is that
this has been central in all the
discussions in France in the last 50
years at the same time as we had this
debate about filiation which was a
debate about the family there was a
debate by affiliation in a different
sense about citizenship who's French and
who's not and so it seems to be the only
reason why we sell the link the two
debates is because the specialists of
gender sexuality tend not to be
special route of immigration but the
specialists of immigration and
citizenship of and in fact it seems to
me that connecting the two appeals is
one of the ways to perceive how the same
issues are taking place of both
conserving PDS us family and concerning
to BSU and I citizenship oh one clear
example is that if by national marriages
why by national narrative on such an
issue event well clearly the patterner
called montage griddle or mahadji should
be an indication the subtle hint the
grace may have saturday too little and
and so it seems to me that tell the
racial issue that is inscribed in
connection was very much implicit in the
late nineteen ninety
early 2000s but it has become more and
more explicit oh but before if I'm I
make this point I want to elaborate on
what I just mentioned without saying
more about the difference between
adoption and access to reproductive
technologies in French public debate
what I find particularly interesting is
that you may have heard oh that was
where they don't announce the puter is
good that he would have follow the
advice of the National ethics counsel on
the issue bathroom without the
technology and everyone who knows the
story knows immediately that it means
it's not going to happen now why would
the government the part for technical
reasons that made it necessary to
separate the two the marriage and
adoption for the issue of access to
reproductive technologies that are not
directly relating to marriage why should
it be more of a problem to open up
access to reproductive technologies than
to dodge why is the difference well then
this has to be in biology and with the
return of biology as a founding logic in
today's political debates and friends
although is by LG in America elevated
that is its biology not just a patch but
as a story that is told extraction
history of the laws of adoption and beba
reproductive technologies the laws are
quite different the laws on adoption are
explicitly artificial if you live that
is you can adopt either as a single
person or as a married couple but you
get out of us as a couple if you're not
married whereas in the case of
reproductive technologies you cannot
have access as a single woman for
example to artificial insemination oh
but if you want to have access as a
couple made up of a man and a woman oh
you need to be married so it's the
opposite watch one is explicitly
artificial the Adlon looks like the
reproductive ash and for example there's
an insistence on the fact that for
access to reproductive technologies you
should be appropriated age which is not
the case for access to adoption so the
natural site is supposed to be on the
side of all procreative reproductive
technologies now one element is the fact
that it looks like nature it looks like
two people in bed
normal what is the price to pay for
preserving this fiction of this
apparently ostensibly natural fiction
the price to pay is what is called in
today's debate resonance resonance means
it has to look true very civility it's
not just possible but it has to resemble
truth now the price way that is is race
that is the main thing about adoption
today is that it tends to be
international adoption which means that
vessel nose is not a founding value in
today's adoption absent and perhaps if
you want to adopt the child is that you
say I'm white and they want to adopt my
child you might be considered racist on
the other hand if you want to have
access to reproductive technologies a
race is there that is there's a
selection of the eggs and there's a
selection of all the sperm to make sure
that there's the same hair color there's
the same eye color and skin color so
race is very much central in the
practices of all reproductive technology
today and this of course have to do with
this idea that you preserve this
sometimes it has to look my biology and
therefore biology forcing trace now what
I want to development now oh honey is
hobbies racial issues have been reshaped
in last few years the first thing that I
would like to point out is that there's
been a big debate in Europe in last ten
years which has resulted in terms such
as sexual nationalism or homeland
nationals Oh does that mean that means
that the instrumentalization of what I
whole sexual democracy those values of
the liberty and equality in terms of
gender and sexuality instrumentalization
in terms of race and immigration has
been central the idea that the
difference between us and them has to do
not with race because we don't believe
in Model T theoretically but with the
fact that they whatever that means they
do not share our democratic values that
is they don't believe in equality they
don't leave of that hok etc etc whereas
the corset so this instrumentalization
of values of sexual democracy in
immigration policies and racialized
discourse important dependency was quite
explicit about this at least on the
heterosexual side margin heterosexuality
since he proclaimed that he was born
metro sexual or a board heterosexuals
experience so because of the incident
I've got so that's when the difference
between us and them that helps justify
in terms that have nothing to do places
the fact that we don't like now what is
interesting is that there have been
reaction to this for example it was
recently in the debate on same-sex
marriage and transitive is a
pronouncement by the spokeswoman
the antigen a unique of the natives of
the Republic ya betcha who explained
repeatedly that basically the issue of
gay marriage was irrelevant for people
in her movement oh because in the volume
they have other problems on one hand
that is to have other priorities oh but
also because after all yes indeed
there's some appropriate value but so
much and finally or she argued that
there was something also that risk that
she was more worried about was getting
earlier than the imposition of gay
identity defined in the west on to not
only other countries but also to the
volume I will have discussed this at
length although as we may have guessed
and not fully convinced by any means now
this is only one reaction but one that I
find interesting as a symmetrical
conversion or to the homo Nationals
version in some ways it says yes you're
right for all we will emphasize racial
issues and we want to get that sexual
issues so it's the opposite of the
instrumentalization
it's the ER version but there's also
another debate that was quite
interesting there was this morning as
well and hast constantly online there
was an announcement that the law would
the law on same-sex marriage would be
vouch guilty the overseas would be left
out of us and of course you had to
remember it was April Fool's Day but
what it showed is something that people
have an itty note that is the tensions
about whether this is a French French
thing not for the colonies of hoops for
the OCS it's not for others it's for us
etc this has been very much perfect and
in fact this deputy
in the National Assembly of deadly from
a geek who insisted that in our culture
we cannot condone this in our culture
and that was interesting because in fact
this is a left-wing that circus breaking
ranks left to say in our culture we
can't do that now what is interesting is
that when as able senses he's playing on
this racialization of the issue of gay
marriage in ways that are very visible
but the part that I'm interested in that
I want to finish with is how it's been
reversed by his temple me up Oh who's
the Minister of Justice in the recent
debates his tempo job is going to have a
law that has her name that web going up
which has been involved on same-sex
marriage a few weeks but she already had
of all that effort name and the 2001
block on slavery all the recognition is
wavering
history and memory of friends now I
think it's quite interesting that she
enlightens both and she's been very
careful during the public debate to
always make this connection obvious the
first speech that she gave included with
a quotation of new boat on that's
courage from Rio her home country Glen
and and what is the Department of what
is interesting is that when she referred
to and then the discussion in June that
is she was attached by rightly deputy
who said you're quoting the husband ms
did not believe in a simulation he
believed in difference and you want to
erase difference so the debate was
taking place about the interpretation of
what a poet from Briana was singing or
hazard and she responded by quoting at
length this poet of displaying more
culture surprisingly than her moment
what was interesting is that this racial
discussion of continued throughout this
particular she responded to us able
rejected community and she responded by
saying how dare you basically how dare
you invoke all the history the legacy of
slavery to say that we should not
support same-sex marriage as he had
and she turn it around by saying it's
precisely as descendants of slaves that
we should favor opening marriage because
we know the importance of freedom and we
know in particular importance of the
freedom to marry so instead of saying
you have to make a choice either indulge
gays and lesbians or you listen to
people of color which is in many ways
what as able to say she's saying it's
the same story it's not either sex or
race it's a combination of both so she's
providing an alternative narrative for
thinking about the connections between
race and gender and sexuality which I
think it's very important and the fact
that she's been such a visible with all
the implications of this term in a
country where the term visible
minorities Oh refers to non-whites so
the fact that she'd been so invisible
including in her clothing in the
National Assembly where the colors were
flamboyant by good news that term I
think the visibility that should try to
play task something to do with this
reversal of the meaning of race and sex
now I'll conclude with one of comparison
of she is reading some people judging
in the US in some ways you may recall
that proposition 8 which is under
discussion today on purpose Supreme
Court proud paid boy was voted coincided
with the election of Veronica bone and
at a time that was appealing that it had
been a great day for african-americans
and bad day for gays and so the idea
that it's either one or the other was
part story including because there were
some figures there were publishing poll
showing that apparently in California
and seventy percent of black voters had
a had supported proposition 8 much more
than watching those were 53 or that
whites were about 50 I will not get into
the discussion of figures but at least
the idea that glass african-americans in
California did not support gay rights
became credit or discussion we had
bargained direction it seems to be very
interesting that Barack Obama and his
inaugural speech when he referred to the
issue of marriage same-sex couples may
all this phrase about that refers to
constitutional principle of truths that
we hold self-evident but of gave of the
narrative which starts from Seneca Falls
goes on to Selma and then goes on to
stonewall that is from the 19th century
1848 women's found the founding moment
of women
to Selma crucial civil rights in 1965
dishonorable crucial to gay rights to be
listening rights 1959 so it seems to me
that basically what brought about was
saying was equivalent to this young to
me I would say but instead of saying
there are several issues that can be
competing issues of both have argued
that you can connect these issues and it
seems to me that it's a complete
reversal from what I described that
happened in the late 1990s in the late
1990s another engine up of in France
what happened we were told we cannot
open filiation because it'd be unnatural
and we have to preserve something by the
French race but also we have to preserve
something like French marriage
today it's precisely in the no trace of
that some black again do not and say
well racial issues and sexual issues are
not in opposition as we heard into yours
2004 they're not working together to
just block any progress or any
questioning but norms on the contrary
it's true grace that you've been
questioning the sexual order and through
sex that you can question the racial
order that's why I think it's an
interesting moment that it's not just
the repetition of something the
trembling French or something eternity
America it seems to be the
reconfiguration of these articulations
and sex and race are quite remarkable in
both lenders
so I am delighted to follow because of
every single one of the topics and we
think about in particular religion
remote sensing gender role of XP several
biology much lesser extent of my whole
race too much greater several long are
saying I want talk about the start
however will sentiment in a minute
quibble with the title of this
presentation apologize to the organizers
it talks about that the marriage fates
which is not something I never have
wanted to discuss I wouldn't even in
this context you want to discuss the
same-sex marriage debate which is what I
often talk about processing of the law
school rather I think it's interesting
to start the comparison with what the
proponents of the opening up of marriage
to same-sex couples are calling the
movement respectively in France United
States in France of course early pension
it's my gosh reduce marriage forever we
interesting they're forced marriage for
everyone because the pox remains
available to both couples of the same
kind of opposite sexes and there is none
of this movement that everyone should
marry I can eat the pasta is not
threaded off by the opening up of my
gosh what is either a legal institution
or as a practical alternative for lots
and lots of people who would have their
life without married by contrast in the
United
the proponents speak of marriage
equality and I think they're doing that
very carefully with respect in respect
to be respectful of those many people in
the gay rights movement and outside of
it who are doubtful that marriage should
have the central role it does in
American long life and call for equality
on the premise you feeling is going to
be marriage then it should be open to
all sorts of couples not there shouldn't
be marriage nevertheless what well mommy
on for tues is not naturally winning
friends marriage equality has turned
into marriage for everyone in the United
States and then I ate much less
congenial to being on zinc levels
any more often the likes of Meg deliver
of the National Organization for
Marriage who claims that she is not on
phobic but simply a proponent of
marriage what I regularly say to her and
she hasn't given an answer to yet is if
you're serious that marriage is what you
are promoting and preserving marriage
and saying that people who are going to
have children off Marron everyone have
to be married you should be kissing the
feet of gaming because nothing has
realized marriage for everyone in the
United States the way the same sex
marriage movement has done both as a
matter of law on alternatives to
marriage or much less talked about much
less available and as a matter of social
practice the notion audience that
everyone out to be very i recently
learned of the engagement of an
false n system right now a long time
someone who is entering into his first
marriage as a senior citizen and on I
said why are you getting married because
the woman I Marian's children think her
mother shouldn't hang around with sundar
she's not getting married the children
are in their early thirties I don't
think that they would have said that but
for the reefs accusation of marriage in
the United States same-sex marriage oh
and I know how to turn to soccer was in
control of religion because a running
theme of my remarks is going to be
things are in some sense the exact
office of what they fear violence is not
bad whereas narrative quality is my a
fortress it is also the case that's in
both france in the united states that we
should not be talked about which cannot
be on its face a justification against
recognizing same-sex marriage is driving
a lot of the debate and that's the role
religion in France you God that
commitment to the ACA the United States
on anyone who's got just a colonial
knowledge of the First Amendment of the
separation of church and state what
should be shocked the way religious and
civil marriage are implicated
instance having such that a minister of
the gospel can simultaneously and
seamlessly do both a simple at a
religious marriage a marriage license is
not a lessons for the couple's marriage
it's a license for the minister from the
same tomorrow so that and any if someone
religiously offer us before marriage
does so without legal significance he or
she is guilty of crying in most states
not as an Indian centriole it won't be
death penalty it's not only a
misdemeanor but religious and civil
marriage or terribly aggregate think is
the only true in France that while
projects is the unique French legal
motions marriage and a family life have
been influenced by Catholic notions
management services were recently
written awesome what has happened in the
United States is that I have been
fascinated to know um Catholics are much
more supportive of same-sex marriage
than for long but all other groups
twenty percent gap between Catholics and
others none of the hierarchy the
Catholic Church isn't supposed to but
I've argued often in the past that the
Catholic Church the ordinary Catholics
are can or not threatened by
because marriage as the state defines it
as their religion defines that are
carefully kept apart in their minds
every Catholic and every observant Jew
knows full well but civil marriage and
religious America not saying because in
both cases they know that it's possible
to be married on personalized stay than
the other the eyes of the faith
Protestants in the United States don't
know that and this is why the objection
design sex marriage that gets left which
is our marriages will be threatened by
same-sex marriage is exactly right when
spoken by a particular event all the
process because Protestants in the
united states have the same relationship
to civil marriage that they four long
I've had to the public schools they had
a nominally state-sponsored institution
that had been co-opted for secretary
enhance and developed an understandable
but not justifiable sense of grievance
when that domination control threaten
Public Schools you've got prayer in
schools the Bible in 1975 Awards grants
was no point
evolution debate still going on today
similarly with respect to marriage
there's no error between our marriage as
Protestants to find it to their flock
and as the state defines in particular
low prospects have not unified the
dissolution of marriage the way
Catholics have development and juice out
through the get in but even beyond that
the rules of marriage so one of my
favorite front backs of the scores that
it wasn't until nineteen ninety nine or
ridicula 1990s that the Southern
Baptists conference declared it to be
part of dallas doctrine and it was a
wife's duty graciously to submit to her
husband servant leadership now it wasn't
the new concept baptist that why should
be subordinate the husband submissive
ties things I'm late eighth century but
until want time they have been able to
tell them seem to do it for them and
that time was an immediate aftermath of
a constitutional revolution against sex
discrimination led by former Columbia
professor and litigator a Supreme Court
justice from their network who made it
impossible for the law to impose
hierarchical sex roles plus
lies when you initiated by sex scrolls
on dozens of lives which leads me to the
second Stephen the question of the role
of sex gender so another thing that
cannot be talked about in the United
States and central to the debates of
France or is sex differentiation as a
justification against same-sex marriage
why is because in the United States the
Ruth Bader Ginsburg off and I sex
discrimination revolution got there
first so that without buying on the
1980s it was unequivocally
constitutional law in the united states
that there could be no fixed rules
concerning the role fixed notions in
certain roles and buildings of males and
females embodied in law and in
particular in the law of merrick a lot
of the cases that gets replicated were
about married couples were some about
nominations organization about male
control over own assets but sundress
about rolled infatuation and spa clearly
there cannot be stereotypes concerning
the roles and abilities of mail it
hasn't gotten through to all lower court
judges
according my James a personal friend
Judge Robert Smith threw up in the Orca
same sex marriage Canyon you said that's
intuition experience suggests an
announcement better for children to grow
up with moving images for them on a
daily basis of what a man an equal
amount of white and my standard nylon
this is given the constitutional
prohibition against stereotypes the only
of an argument for medium home like
unless what he was arguing that
recognizes six hours that i'm at walmart
like your mom but any of it at the level
of constitutional law this argument
cannot be on the table in the United
States although is central to the
motives of many of the religious and
some of the non-religious opponents of
same-sex marriage so they would like it
burn but has now had a new revelation
concerning same-sex merapi and the
expert witness actually the testify
for the primates I'd start an argument
against single mother blood in
particular poor black single color hood
in favor of useless family locator we
needed to reestablish the patriarchy and
the role of fathers and sexual
differentiation I know as recently as
prop eight oral arguments I was
fascinating to see Cooper the lawyer
arguing for lagrave a performance saying
that the risk to same-sex marriage was
that there would be a genderless action
genderless marriage with something very
worries on now let's get to a personal
equivalents to meet and tragedy is too
strong the arguments based in the notion
of sex discrimination being
unconstitutional probably have not been
front and center in the same sex
marriage it's particularly in the same
sex marriage it's worth Supreme Court us
take care sorry that they've learned to
Justice Kennedy which we all know this
is sweet voter ask unfortunately Cooper
this is actually gender based
classification ends of rescue personnel
if it were seen as a sex based
classification will be
you know but note that this is gender
based rather than sex face he's gets the
back to the role of sex and gender &
fresh bait it is also seems to me more
than a little and just slightly less
than tragic that since the time of the
French Revolution the French have been
unwilling to extend to women ah the full
equal impersonal citizenship at the
revolution established for all men women
lost voting rights in French Revolution
when they had had since the estate's
both fair and 14th century they did get
back into laughter over two and pi a has
rien something like about a good notion
of complementarity in French warmth that
it takes both males and females to
compete of the human race and that we
are not as Ratzinger has been in the
16th reminds us nearly human that it is
dangerous over my human bracelet that's
identity was like I should want to Arlen
so one of the things that are Ratzinger
and jean-paul to and a some of the
talking
french maid personal favorite is lavake
and police Tony and latrella are have
focus is this notion that sexual
complementarity but which they don't
mean what's wrong George was the
American natural log errors from the
calendars that a purely by logistic
notion of sexual complementarity and
it's sort have a slot B notion
advancement yeah the genitalia are
complimentary what they do mean is what
became clear from these days about
logistics that's it is blue trust
suggests exactly once resided ensberg
persuaded us was our constitutional
commitment so persuasive that even
justice Rehnquist wrote one of his last
important opinion saying we're so
admitted to this federal government
imposing on the states there should be
no stereotypical notions of the roles of
behaviour solid mass people's word or
the flesh contest but notion that there
anything but essential sex defines that
the culture plans of
a role was seen as so problematic that
the hundreds of Deputies not just like
those led by the Catholic Church the
Mandela's role of the text books that
body has dangerous gender theory and so
childer which the Vatican has said its
face against it has two meanings both of
which are dangerous to a Catholic notion
of commentary that needs to opposition
to same-sex marriage France one is the
way that people on this side of
Amsterdam out we would use to come and
that is to say the one favorite among
Women's and Gender Studies folks that
gender is the societal and cultural
overlay on biological sex the other is
the way that Ruth Bader Ginsburg put it
into law in American law which is the
migrated to international law to the
Beijing conference which is not that
gender is a social construction for the
gender is a synonym for sex but when the
gender is used as a synonym for sex
wrong sociated with a
it says there is no fixed biological
difference are important to the law that
differences should be and stereotype
differences should not be the basis of
legal categories so things have been
open to the French that are for clothes
to the Americans with respect to saying
we need to reinforce gender differences
not just biological sex and this is a
reason for opposing nonsense that's not
now Ellie said pulling up the Bible was
the samisen in France and it would have
been at four of us Congress oh one other
things with the motion which is that the
cultural region cannot be explicitly
discussed there was a smooth from the
emotional anthropology philosophical
anthropology and is shift from religion
to psychoanalysis and famously someone
got up on the floor of the french
assembly and so it would destroy this
pollock order if couples of the same sex
get married I think Americans would
agree that no one would have any
what would be talked about if something
up for us and said even destroyed or
moral some pretty but two arguments from
cycle analysis even Freud when lon con
or have interestingly knotted on cable
in the united states but i also want to
talk about the different way in english
expertise is used on anthropology or
sociology the abstract versus the
concrete and pure gold euro and again a
lot of what is happening it seems to be
pissed at spawn in france is that
there's a slippage between theological
and philosophical anthropology and the
clean is made that not just the kids
actually raised by same-sex couples but
all trim this is the planet of the time
of a pox gatherers receded but all
children might grow up psychotic if sex
differences were not precisely in body
through all the idea of same-sex
marriage would destroy us and i am
troubled that the folks of about marine
for us gets too limited in
pretation on to the question of
heterosexuality when it seems perfectly
clear in contacts that the Pope was
talking about a general sweep of fixed
notions concerning the roles and its
appearance he did me the tag line folks
as heterosexuality a new bike light rain
forest is assessment the distinction
when she talks about the nature of human
being as a young female and I find very
fascinating that the Vatican believes
that here is more connection than
unfortunately I know there to be between
all kinds of movements like the feminist
movement the reproductive rights
movement the movement to reform family
law the gay rights on all of these
things the Pope connects up as it might
be an a so called gender agenda whereas
there isn't the same seeing of
connections and making political
alliances and therefore not the same
power so when you wouldn'ta Pope
compares the proponents of the gender
agenda two or said that
a human ecology that we need to observe
I feel together the policies people
might be like honey as well um probably
most of you in this room as the
equivalent for major human beings as
environmentalists sea lions we are going
to clear-cut through human nature ah
fascinates me that he thinks but it is
possible he thinks it would be a really
bad idea to destroy human nature but he
thinks just as it is possible to destroy
ready for us it is possible to destroy
complementarity which in some sense
concedes that it is a bit of a social
construction or at least not a boy um so
the other thing that executes that I
would say is a very abstract in France
very particular in the United States we
look if at all to evidence-based studies
of how same-sex families are actually
doing and interesting like it's true
that the better the studies are for the
same-sex families it turns out it's
Supreme Court the worse it is for their
prospects to marriage Roberts pointed
out that given when the same-sex
families were doing so well the argument
that they needed marriage either
kept their rights practical level check
their rights and symbolic level perhaps
that case have been made it wants to
crack me too okay any wings yeah so I
will just say one little thing about the
comparative role of race and second the
notion that you're interesting things we
said about the comparison between sleep
experiences in the possibility of
marriage affiliation and the experiences
of the possibility of American
affiliation and point out that's just
Scalia as a given for saying exactly the
wrong thing I'm actually working on a
piece called deconstructing Sofia which
one book Yogi's are being able to reveal
its Miller textual sense right take the
text put pressure on and the whole thing
explodes he did it again in the oral
argument when Justice Kagan said what
about two people who are 55 years old if
Mary is really for reproduction why you
allow
Mary he interjected that obviously
strong firm and had not been the chair
of the Judiciary Committee
nomination hearings and what he probably
thought he had a bike was strong
currents have a very old age as serious
with white beauty queens what he what
putting pressure on the text opens up is
a poor stronger and also have a child
with you with a black servant in his
family home serving through me
just briefly because i want to taik
about strategize one thing is an obvious
difference between our talks between the
situations in france in the u.s. is the
status of law the very fact that it's
careful about how all works penalty
needs work incomparable by that you had
170 of legal scholars who can publish a
text in opposition to same-sex marriage
with basically not one valid legal
argument recently says something about
the law it's not that important in
French debate is of course the law is
important in that it defines the land
but not in theoretical debates always
seems to me oh and the second thing that
I do point out about the presence of
gender role as the legal reality in
France there was the case of Trance
marriage that was rejected by a court in
2005 and the problem was towards to
justify how to forbid this marriage oh
and they had
in fact for the law all this was a
mountain wound oh these were two women
wanted to get married but one had
undergone surgery and the other one not
and therefore were still considered one
of the math so how can you say no to
this it's very difficult and so the
court came up with a gender argument by
saying that consent in marriage requires
the intention to behave as man and wife
and so since these two women that they
couldn't say women because for the law
is about equipment but since they did
not intend to behave as my wife it could
be authorized which shows the lengths
they're willing to go to to justify
making life rules and just one last
remark about when we prepared the
religion marriage thing about civil
marriage and religious marriage just a
reminder of the fact that in France you
need civil marriage before you get
religious marriage all so it's quite a
west but it's an important element it's
been used
the suspicion that Muslims are getting
married without going to the mini and so
this